you know what I'm eating I'm eating my
mom's kimbap kimbap is it's like Korean
sandwiches it's like the equivalent of
sandwiches for why do I always do that
but I always talk about white people you
know wives any grope you guys I don't
understand you
help me understand you able to go wrong
into now I'm back home to Sacramento
California my hometown shout out noun 1
sizzle but as you guys may already know
I moved to LA roughly about about four
years ago now when I moved to LA it was
a very huge culture shock for me because
I grew up in Sacramento my whole life
and the only time I really lived outside
of it was when I went to UCR for a
couple of years but other than that
Sacramento has been my world I live in
this bubble now when I came back home to
my small town I started to realize how
much I like people from Sacramento there
are certain things that I like about a
smaller city than I do a bigger city now
let's say everybody in Elia is like this
what I am saying is the people that are
in LA that I try to make it an
entertainment you know what I'm talking
about those people they glamorize a
certain life that they're not a part of
it ever since they were a kid or they
heard about the great land of Los
Angeles they want to live that life I'm
selling some dick tonight there are a
few type of people that you will meet
here in Los Angeles that you just might
hate but y'all right know what it is LG
out baby let's get it let's go the name
dropper hey this person V moves these
type of people who name drop they feel
that they are just as important as the
people that they are around I'm sorry
but you're not so if your colleagues are
successful why aren't you successful
because that [__] just doesn't make
sense to me
so instead of actually doing [__] and
trying to do things about it they just
talk about their famous friends subject
what'd you do yesterday oh you know me
man I'll just kickin it with my friend
maybe you heard of him Justin Bieber who
really did we just go name drop like
that fine [__] I'm a name drop
somebody even bigger than you maybe you
heard of my homie Jesus Christ that's
right [__] that's the son of God talk
about
drop name drop past that this is my
homie Buddha this is my homie form and I
guess if you lived in Metropolis and
that you just happen to name drop
Superman to [__] I may be heard my homie
ah ha no Superman do you feel that
unimportant that you have to mention
important people things in order for you
to feel better your self esteem is loud
and I don't want people to tell me to
feel bad for them I don't have to feel
bad for you just fix your [__] [__]
because every day we have to hear it
[__] I'm just gonna start
name-dropping random people to guess who
almost you're getting with yesterday Oh
your mom I [__] her number to the I
know this person it's way different than
the name dropper see the name dropper
you already previously know who that
person is the I know this person is to
tell you that you know somebody else who
got a lot of money [__] do you got a
lot of money why the [__] do you care
about how much money somebody got in
their pockets it's not in your pocket so
why the [__] do I want to hear about
what you don't have dude last time I was
with this dude he was at a strip club
he was just throw in like
thousand-dollar bills on the flower well
did you get up offering basket and
[__] collect [__] give me 5
grand see how fast I spread my booty
cheeks have you all hardly say what you
eat don't make me [__] talking about how
deep somebody else's pockets on doesn't
make your pockets any better you are not
successful by association you are
successful because of things that you do
not what somebody else has done number
three the I Drive a nice car but live in
a [__] [__] place cuz that should
make sense to you
why the [__] do you have the people in
these big cities live way beyond their
means and you're the weird [__] issue
was never a bother when you grow up so
why the [__] is is so important now for
me I grew up with nothing I'm fine with
nothing if this [__] gets all taken away
tomorrow well huh no I will find a side
hustle I started up as a stand-up
comedian [__] I will be back in
those comedy clubs doing this Star Jones
Rob I walk into a bar ha you can't stop
this
the [__] you are so worried about
what you look like to other people
you're not actually doing something with
your [__] life I want to look rich
why don't you be rich they say people
are so funny because they got this nice
ride they got a [__] place they got good
Club it a lot of [__] single penny to
that [__] name they could barely pay
their bill they're always stressed about
money but it's [__] that they're doing
but they're still complaining about it
makes no sense you should [__] living
like that Ke$ha song wake up in an irony
feeling light pink Danny you wake up in
the morning feeling like P Duty [__] mm
and by the way people there are a lot of
great people in Los Angeles and big
cities like New York City and stuff like
that
I'm just generalizing a lot of the
people that I have met here and the big
city of entertainment let me ask you
what type of people in the big city rub
you the wrong way oh [__] oh how I hit
my toe on a [__] tripod what the back
it's my girlfriend I was telling that I
love it